next question
i recently got my masters from an
oxbridge college
just after racial bias training became
mandatory for current and future
students
is a phd worth the personal cost of
speaking untruths
well yeah you know this is a tough one
i i have been saying to our children
that in many ways i don't think
i could do what they must now do
living in a world in which untruths are
so
uh regularly deployed and with such um
such force behind them um so i don't
know what to make
of this because obviously there is a
logic about living to fight another day
this is something it took me a long time
to
understand but you know there's only so
far you can go with that and then the
other thing is
if you decide well live to fight another
day has to be the key rubric because if
you're going to accomplish something
you have to accomplish that first that's
like the second half of is this the hill
you want to die on
right i mean even if those don't emerge
from the same thing it's
it's definitely you can definitely put
those two ideas together and make them
sing yeah they they um they are closely
related and the problem is this isn't
the hill you want to die on then you're
going to live to fight another day
right if the person asking you if that's
the hill you want to die on
is also holding a weapon it's a very
different thing
and so yes the the problem i would say
is
you know none of us gets out alive there
probably is a hill you should therefore
be willing to die on
right there are important things in the
world and you the preservation of your
well-being is not um ultimately
viable especially if you are part of a
society that
is committing obvious suicide
right so the hill to die on is somewhere
and
uh we all ought to find that hill
i don't know what to do you know i have
almost no doubt
that i would not i mean i barely
survived the phd program we went through
at the time and this was not a component
of the problem so
yep wasn't there no it wasn't there
there were lots of other problems and
my you know instinct to go after things
that aren't right definitely got me in a
lot of trouble but it was scientific
trouble
um and you know kind i'm proud of i
think the fights i
chose were were good ones and i would
still think that even if i
hadn't hadn't finished but but
nonetheless i don't know what advice to
give people going now because on the one
hand
the institutional structure is so broken
that it's not obvious to me that having
the degree and therefore the authority
or having
the training and therefore the knowledge
is all that valuable
in and of itself because the programs
are um delusional in the first place for
the most part so
well i mean
that will obviously vary to some degree
by discipline
and the problem more widely is you know
if this person says
um mandatory for current future students
it's not clear
if in this question racial bias training
is mandatory
in this field you know for for that
department yep or if it's college-wide
yes
increasingly these things are becoming
college-wide and we saw evidence
you know we saw yet more evidence this
week from a couple of terrific pieces
one written by barry weiss one written
by
caitlyn flanagan on what is happening to
secondary ed
especially the elite private schools and
you know it's whole institutions they're
falling to this thing
um but presumably the world does still
need
um chemists and you know like so
i i fear that art which we need will
fall completely as a set of disciplines
sooner than this
than the stem fields will uh because
airplanes will start falling out of the
sky and bridges will start collapsing
well but i mean in some sense this is my
point
is we do absolutely need these things
not optional and you cannot do it in a
world where
your relationship to the truth is held
to be facultative
as a matter of your survival
therefore we are facing an existential
crisis and that does not mean that it is
clear that if you go into the field
that ultimately things sort out the
question is
is it necessary if your point is
actually chemistry is very very
important and we have to
remain clear-headed about it then the
point is maybe that has to be fought
outside that if you go if you go into
the thing that it owns and therefore can
force you
to accept fiction that it woken us not
it chemistry
correct chemistry having surrendered to
wokeness and i
can speak less about what's going on in
chemistry biology yeah yeah but biology
clearly has
right otherwise there would be an uproar
amongst biologists saying actually
that's that nonsense that you're
peddling over at scientific american
about
us having gotten past the sexual binary
is nonsense and
you know now when you get people who can
legitimately say
how can you claim that sex is binary
when all of these
researchers and scientists and
pediatricians and such say the other
like well i can't explain them but that
doesn't make them right
yeah so what you know this goes back to
the idea of zero being a special number
right to the extent that there are not
programs that we can point you to where
the chemistry is free
of wokeness that tells you what battle
we're involved in we're battle in a
battle in which
there can be no program in which
chemistry is not
afflicted by wokeness because if there
was it would obviously be the top
program and therefore
if if the outsiders can race to the
front of the race just simply by not
being crazy
then the point is that cannot be allowed
which is actually why do we go after
merit right which is quite viewable
in the attack on sub stack this week so
there are now
calls to i don't know this sub stack um
sensor it's journalists and the point is
well
we can't very well have a game in which
all of the mainstream outlets
have to say these crazy wrong things if
they're a bunch of people
who are liberated to go to the audience
directly and say true things because of
course
they will be the only game in town so
how can they not be the only game in
town
we're gonna have to d platform so i
didn't i didn't know that it happened um
i met with the two founders of sub stack
a few years ago back before
really almost anyone had heard of them
and they were they came they flew up
here to
to talk to me about whether or not i
wanted to start one and i was thinking
about and i ended up not and
i still don't have one as as you know um
but i specifically asked them i think
this was
right after the kerfuffle with patreon
over sargon of akkad and i was thinking
okay maybe not patreon maybe
sub stack i tend to want to put out more
written content anyway than video
content
um and i was really impressed with with
these two guys but i asked them
specifically what
you know what will your policy be in
censorship space and um
they didn't hedge a lot but they hedged
just a tiny bit and you know i
felt it was it was not that that is the
reason that i didn't end up creating a
substance i didn't want
at that point we i think we had maybe
just gotten our book contract i didn't
want to feel confined to be writing
something on a regular basis for that
for a different audience um but
i remember the three of us having a
conversation that i think was was good
on all fronts in which i said
you will you will want to be very clear
up front with this
because it will come for you yes it will
come for you the question is what do you
say because of course you don't want to
set up a policy that allows people to
put
truly dangerous possibly illegal
whatever it is so you need to set up a
rule
that explains how discretion will be
willed and what will be protected
but that you know i don't envy anybody
who has to write that policy and then
face the consequences it's not a simple
matter
i agree